Human beings are a curious, inquisitive, exploratory
species.
I think that has been the secret of our success
as a species.
We now have reached a point in human history,
when all the Earth is explored;
there are no new places to explore on the Earth.
At just this moment, these spacecraft permit
us, in a halting, tentative, preliminary way,
to leave the Earth and examine our surroundings in space.
An enterprise which I believe is in the truest
human tradition of exploration and discovery.
We are at an epochal moment.
Our machines, and eventually ourselves, are going out into space.
I believe that the history of our species
will never again be the same.
We have committed ourselves to space, and
I do not think we are about to turn back.
Artefacts from Earth are spinning out
into the cosmos. I believe the time will come
when most human cultures will be engaged in
an activity we might describe
as a dandelion going to seed.
(An enterprise which I believe is in the truest
human tradition.)
(A dandelion, going to seed.)